bonjour jean marc sylvestre heureuse de
vous retrouver ce matin dans la matinale
verte et france alors on a fait un point
déjà assez développée sur le tourisme
c'est une question cruciale pour le
monde entier si je puis dire
la france qui vient donc de lancer une
campagne de communication pour séduire
les touristes et convaincre les
convaincre de venir en france
convaincre aussi les français de rester
dans l'hexagone le secrétaire d'état au
tourisme on l'a vu veut un était bleu
blanc rouge
quel est l'enjeu de cette saison qui va
s'ouvrir début juin vous savez je vais
considérer les chiffres sont très
simples le tourisme en france c'est
aussi importants que l'agriculture ou
les industries du luxe ce sont les trois
grandes industries qui sont les moteurs
de notre pays de notre produit intérieur
brut notre production intérieure au 8
mai dans ce tiers c'est bien c'est le
sait le tourisme qui a le plus souffert
de la pandémie le tourisme basse et bien
sûr les hôtels qui sont restés fermés
très longtemps les restaurants qui sont
encore fermées aujourd'hui
les campings les parcs à thème le puy du
fou euro disney vous connaissez tout ça
les monuments de paris les musées bref
c'est une immense richesse qui donne du
travail à plus de 3 millions de
personnes 1 3 million d'emplois au total
ça génère 60 milliards de richesse ça
générait 60 milliards de richesse avants
locaux vides et ça a tiré 90 millions de
touristes français et étrangers chaque
touriste dépense environ 700 euros
pendant son voyage à la france je vous
dis ça parce que la france et en europe
le pays qui attire le plus de tourisme
mais nos touristes mais les touristes
qui viennent chez nous dépenses à un peu
moins d'argent que ceux qui vont en
espagne par exemple où ils sont pourtant
moins nombreux mais pourquoi on dépense
moins d'argent chez les patients restent
moins longtemps ou on n'est pas sage
dont il faut il faut essayer de scotch
et un peu les touristes que chez new
line une dépense joue 10 à 700 euros
c'est à dire moins d'argent que le
touriste qui va en espagne j'ajoute une
chose la pandémie a réduit de moitié on
l'a vu dans vos reportages que le
chiffre le chiffre d'affaires du
tourisme donc l'enjeu de déconfinement
est considérable il faut être absolument
prêt pour la fin juin il faut retrouver
ces touristes d'où cette campagne de
sensibilisation alors cette campagne
vise des étrangers vous l'avez dit mais
ça va pas être évident parce que la
france est quand même considérer je
crois dans le monde entier notamment en
europe comme un des pays à risque un peu
comme l'espagne ou l'italie mais cette
campagne
elle va viser aussi des français pour
qu'il reste chez nous et ça ça va être
assez passionnant à suivre parce que la
concurrence est quand même rude
quels sont les atouts alors on peut
mettre en avant alors économiquement les
vents les connaît il ya des atouts
naturels
le ministre en a parlé hier dans sa
communication c'est le pays le plus
riche en diversité géographique la mer
la montagne mais ça a payé aussi où les
traces de l'histoire les traces de la
culture sont considérablement
saint-michel ouais tout le monde adore
le vent ça michel le château de
versailles les châteaux de la loire tout
ça est resté vide là pendant des mois
tout ça on connaît mais on a des
concurrents en europe
l'italie a une attractivité touristique
très forte peas vérone rome mais la
campagne de publicité va avoir pour
objectif surtout de rassurer des acteurs
du tourisme et surtout les clients et
peut-être même les clients qui ont
beaucoup d'argent c'est à dire les
américains tentent pourra sans doute on
aura du mal à refaire venir les chinois
pour l'instant parce qu'il ya des des
obstacles mais mais mais mais l'enjeu va
être là le genre je vais être là donc 1
il faut que le déconfinement se passe
bien et ça c'est une question de
sécurisation c'est pas évident compte
tenu des normes de protection et michal
ça c'est compliqué les restaurateurs
notamment du mal à savoir quelle jose
qui vont pouvoir utiliser et si cette
jauge leur permettra d'avoir des
coefficients de rentabilité suffisants
et puis deuxièmement il faut assurer la
sécurité sanitaire dont il faut
accélérer la vaccination le testing
régler cette question du passeport
sanitaires ou vaccinale qui fait débat
qu'on a du mal à accepter alors
l'assemblée nationale s'est fait un peu
tirer les oreilles irl a eu du mal à le
voter y est allée à reculons
ça prouve quand même qu'à l'intérieur du
pays va y avoir un problème pour la
vaccination
il ya on est quand même très très en
retard il ya beaucoup de gens qui vont
se faire vacciner en mai juin mais ça
veut dire que la deuxième dose il va
falloir la faire pendant les vacances
donc il va falloir refaire une
logistique de vaccination près des lieux
de mer et là l'administration est en
train d'y réfléchir et ne va pas pour
apporter beaucoup de précision jusqu'à
maintenant oui alors que jean castex a
et qu'on pouvait se faire vacciner sur
son lieu de villégiature mais on verra
si c'est possible mais est ce que
l'europe elle avance de façon unie et
coordonnées on a du mal à y voir clair
dans les
classements en tout cas un bon bah c'est
normal la réponse qui soit et non mais
de toute façon la politique de santé et
pas du cadre européen et que les pays
soient en concurrence
c'est pas normal parce que les
situations sont différentes on peut pas
demander par exemple en france de
régionaliser les campagnes de
vaccination où les campagnes de
protection
et puis une panne ne pas l'accepter au
niveau européen mais l'europe a en
projet de créer ce passeport sanitaire
qui permettrait aux porteurs d'aller un
peu partout en europe mais a du retard
et ça s'adresse surtout aux concurrents
et rendent aux concurrents étrangers aux
touristes américains l'i-phone
américains viennent en france ils
viennent pas en fente enfants qui
viennent en europe
ils viennent visiter paris vienne rome
et insultes dont il faut qu'ils puissent
circuler avec bardot thierry breton
pousse les feux la mémé ça marche si
tout le monde l'adapter pour l'instant
tout le monde n'a pas adopté alors comme
tous les pays sont concurrents incertain
comme l'espagne la grèce l'italie
veulent prendre les devants on l'a vu
tout à l'heure pour attirer les
touristes et engranger des réservations
la grèce c'est vrai a annoncé très tôt
que beaucoup de ces îles seront co vide
0 la grèce a déjà reçu des réservations
nombreuses en provenance de la
grande-bretagne aux etats-unis ce sont
deux pays en europe qui est le plus en
avant cela sur les réservations
actuellement mais mais mais la met la
france en en france même on se réserve
des gens pour aller en grèce mais
beaucoup de touristes français qui ont
déjà pris leurs réservations pour les
d'en saisir
en espagne aussi en italie mais assez
peu pour venir en france donc c'est
toujours la méfiance
compte tenu des conditions la france est
en retard parce qu'elle ne peut pas
garantir aux touristes que tout sera
fait pour assurer sa sécurité
il faudrait être prêt au 30 juin mais on
n'est pas sûr de la situation alors le
pays qui s'en sortent sont ceux qui
imposent un passeport vaccinale parfois
un test négatif de -2 72 heures avec
encore des conditions restrictives mais
c'est très rassurant pour le visiteur
convient des conditions restrictives
c'était embêtant pour les acteurs mais
c'est rassurant
les filles qui souffre actuellement
faire fermer sont rares il ya le
danemark et la norvège
il ya la tchéquie le croit la hongrie la
russie aussi avec des restrictions
assiste actuellement pour les touristes
mais nous ne sommes qu'à la mine
et donc ça va évoluer tout ça hein
l'enjeu est énorme de disques c'est
l'équation que cette industrie doit
résoudre est affreusement compliquée il
faut accueillir le maximum de touristes
avec le minimum de risques sanitaires
cédiez parce que pas question de
provoquer une quatrième vague en
septembre
comme l'année dernière les îles sont
favorisées puisqu'elles sont fermées la
grèce par exemple peut assez facilement
isolé sésime malte va encore plus loin
malte va offrir un chèque de 200 euros
par personne pour séjourner au moins
trois jours donc si vous cherchez une
idée de vacances bas dépêchez vous de
réserver parce que cette offre est
limitée aux 30 u et 1000 premières
réservations y en a déjà une grande
partie qu'une prise
merci pour la publicité pour malte
jean-marc merci de malte c'est une île
qui est d'ailleurs très prisé que vous
de savoir sa part des touristes russes
elle va très bien maintenant on le saura
merci beaucoup en tout cas pour toutes
ces précisions précieuse en tout cas
pour savoir où on va partir en vacances
cet été
jean marc sylvestre